welcome back to the david pakman show i
am substitute teacher jesse dolimore
yesterday as a matter of follow-up i
talked about rand paul in a video he put
on youtube that was just filled to the
brim with anti-science propaganda
anti-mask rhetoric
um come and arrest us they can't arrest
us all he said
and uh it got him suspended got his
youtube temporarily suspended by youtube
uh i'm gonna read from this new york
times article talking about it and then
we're gonna hear
the brave
man of action rand paul's response on
twitter
uh youtube suspends rand paul for a week
over video disputing the effectiveness
of masks now listen
in a time
the time in which we're living through a
pandemic for for going on two years now
where we have been uh
holed up in our houses if you're taking
it seriously and and then this new norm
of wearing masks to protect one another
it is a strange time
and it's the weakest among us
morally weak ethically weak
mentally weak among us like rand paul
who insist
on pushing back against mass mandates
when the cdc has said clearly
with with with study after study after
study that they prevent the spread they
slow the spread it's not it's not an
ultimate prevention that yes it's over
you'll never get covered if you wear a
mask
but absolutely it's a mitigation effort
reading from this new york times article
youtube on tuesday removed a video by
senator rand paul of kentucky for the
second time and suspended him from
publishing for a week after he posted a
video that disputed the effectiveness of
wearing masks to limit the spread of the
coronavirus
now if you'd like to watch the video
you can watch the full david pakman show
program uh or the the the isolated clip
when it's posted but i we posted and
played a lot of it
reacted to it
a youtube representative said the
republican senator's claims in the
three-minute video had violated the
company's policy on covet 19 medical
misinformation
the company policy bans videos that
spread a wide variety of misinformation
including claims that masks do not play
a role in preventing the contraction or
transmission
of covid19
we apply this is youtube we apply our
policies consistently across the
platform regardless of speaker or
political views
and we make exceptions
as in the case of my talking about it
yesterday and we make exceptions for
videos that have additional context such
as countervailing views from local
health authorities
the representative said in a statement
in the video mr paul says quote most of
the masks you get over the counter don't
work
they don't prevent infection end quote
later in the video he adds quote
trying to shape human behavior isn't the
same as following the actual science
which tells us that cloth masks don't
work end quote
in fact
masks do work according to the near
unanimous recommendations of public
health experts
the cdc
it said in november
that wearing face masks reduce the
spread of the virus and that quote
individual benefit increases with
increasing community mass use
and a study aboard the uss theodore
roosevelt
indicated that 70
decrease in transmission just from
wearing masks
what is rand paul doing
to what truth
is he obligated he is supposedly
a man of science he is supposedly a
doctor
and this is the way he responded on
twitter a badge of honor
leftwing cretans at youtube
banning me for seven days for a video
that quotes two peer-reviewed articles
saying cloth masks don't work
if you want to see the band video go to
liberty tree and he promotes some
ding dong free speech website
if you'd like to see the video
i play a little bit of it and react to
it that's where you go
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of our awesome
sponsors today one of those awesome
sponsors is sheath underwear
a lot of us know all too well about the
sticking and the rubbing and the chafing
with traditional underwear especially
this time of year as the weather is
getting warm
sheath underwear have created unique
boxer briefs with multiple ergonomic
compartments in the front preventing
skin on skin contact everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver sheath
underwear is giving the david pakman
show audience 20 off when you go to
sheath underwear dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman give
sheath underwear a shot i've had a great
experience i believe you will too you
can find the link underneath this video
and don't forget to use promo code
pacman for 20 off